la siguiente tabla representa una
ecuación lineal veamos que está
sucediendo en la tabla
cuando x vale menos 7 que tiene el valor
de 4 luego cuando x vale menos 37 toma
el valor de 3 el cambio en el valor de x
y lo escribiré acá el cambio en el valor
de x
y va de menos 7 a menos 3 quiere decir
que tuvo un incremento de 4 unidades o
el cambio es de más 4 el cambio de iu y
aquí voy a mencionar que este triángulo
es la letra griega delta es el símbolo
que se utiliza para denotar el cambio en
el valor de una variable
entonces estábamos aquí el cambio de
jeff a la vez que x cambia en incrementa
en 4 unidades o en + 4 el valor de lleva
de 4 a 3
esto quiere decir que decremento en una
unidad o cambia el menos 1
ahora bien para que los valores de esta
tabla puedan representar una ecuación
lineal la razón entre el cambio de ye y
de x debe ser constante así que el
cambio de entre x para cualesquiera par
de puntos en la tabla debe ser la misma
cuando x cambia o incrementa en 4
unidades y decremento en una por lo
tanto la razón es
del taller sobre delta de x que es menos
1 sobre 4
vamos a checar si la razón de cambio
entre cualesquiera de los puntos es esta
misma constante
la siguiente razón de cambio sale de ir
de menos 3 a 1 en x
nuevamente incrementamos en 4 unidades y
de 3 a 2 en 10 nuevamente es un
decremento de una unidad es la misma
razón de cambio
finalmente tomemos los últimos dos
puntos en x va de 1 a 7 por lo que hay
un incremento de 6 unidades y en jeff va
de 2 a 1 y se mantiene el decremento de
una unidad
en este caso la razón de cambio entre
los dos últimos puntos no sigue la razón
de cambio anterior es distinta la razón
del cambio entre estos dos últimos
puntos
menos un sexto
entonces tenemos una razón diferente de
iu con respecto a x y por tanto podemos
decir que esta tabla no representa una
ecuación lineal